The first answer is ide.udacity.com. And again, that
makes sense for the same reason as, as
before. If the domains match, it's a simple
case. Of course this domain can set this cookie.
The second answer, other.ide.udacity.com. This basically means if
other can set a cookie for its parents.
Which works fine. What, what is not a
correct answer is udacity.com. Other.ide can't set a cookie
for udacity which would set to, you know, any sub-domain of
udacity. And it can't set a cookie for, you know, a sibling.
Other.udacity.com can't set this cookie. Only these two domains can set
this cookie. I want you to be aware that the domain you're
setting a cookie for is very important. And, you know, of
course, when you are developing software you can just experiment and see
which ones work. But these are the general rules. You know, just,
just look for, you know, either a direct match or the server.
Or the cookie should be a subset of the
server. And you're in and you're in good shape.